bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
pour ce nouveau numéro de la voyez mon
invité aujourd'hui c'est bruno belin le
président les républicains du conseil
départemental de la vienne bonjour ou
nobles un bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté ou mon habitation avant de
revenir sur l'actualité qui vous
concerne précisément jouez vous entendre
la réaction drame de rochefort qui a
fait six morts donc jeudi quand un
événement comme celui-ci donc arrive
est-ce qu'on se sent touché
personnellement on se sent touché
d'abord en tant que parent on imagine la
douleur des parents
et on se sent touché d'abord parce que
on est aussi parents d'élèves et puis
parce que malheureusement je l' ai vécu
en tant qu élu en mars 2007
j'ai eu la lourde tâche d'aller
annonçait une famille la disparition
d'un enfant dans un accident de car et
donc ça on oublie jamais et donc j'ai
pensé à mes amis de charente maritime
hervé blanché dominique bussereau qui
ont eu à vivre cette journée là
évidemment surtout aux familles aux
secours au chauffeur
évidemment il est trop tôt pour parler
de ce qui s'est passé ou du moment les
causes c'est sûr quand on est président
d'un département comme le vôtre paysans
de la vienne est épuisée en charge
justement des transports scolaires c'est
le genre de drame que l'on peut redouter
ça fait partie du quotidien alors
évidemment on y pense on l'anticipent
vous savez qu'il ya eu déjà d'édition
importantes concernant les transports
scolaires sur l'obligation de ceinture
l'obligation d'éthylomètres mais il ya
aussi y an depuis l'accident 2007
c'est partie grâce à la mobilisation qui
avait eu sur l'accident de mars 2007
l'association qui avait monté rome
abonnés après le décès de son petit
frère
ils lui rappellent à la sécurité
justement pour les chauffeurs il ya des
rappels permanent et à la sécurité et
aussi ce qu'on fait dans la vienne deux
formations kit sensibilisation à tous
les enfants de 6e quand il rentre en
sixième ça fait partie des messages
auxquels on est très attaché on y pense
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on pense
fortement à nos amis de
charente-maritime et à ces familles
touchées alors bruno belin en dehors de
ces justement de cet événement
dramatique l'actualité est marquée
depuis plusieurs semaines donc par une
certaine drogue
on va les listes est grande elle n'est
pas exhaustive cette grogne des
agriculteurs grogne contre la baisse des
dotations de l'état grogne des agents
territoriaux grogne des élus contre la
fameuse carte de l'intercommunalité pour
reprendre la fameuse phrase d'un certain
général de gaulle
est ce que c'est la chienlit bruno
collin il ya sans doute
peut-être d'un manque de savoir faire de
la part de des dirigeants
gouvernementaux surtout sur les
questions de ruralité et notamment
agricoles on voit bien que c'est un
sujet qu'il aurait complètement étranger
j'ai vu encore la semaine dernière la
détresse du monde agricole
quand j'entends avant-hier suicide d'un
jeune agriculteur éleveur d'un côtes
d'armor 38 ans père de famille on se dit
aussi voilà il est urgent de changer
absolument de cap
donc je crois qu'il est effectivement
grand temps j'ai appris on appris
avant-hier soir dans la manie mans le
recyclage ministériel qui a eu ça vous
rassure il y à un menu chargé de la
ruralité ça fait partie des
préoccupations c'est la bonne personne
pour pouvoir répondre justement désarroi
des agriculteurs maximise la culture ne
change pas lui richard riot ripose itif
sur le ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire et de la ruralité
jean-michel bagley pour l'unité
présidents de départements d'un
département rural
il sait de quoi il parle c'est important
alors on a moins de 5 justement du salon
de l'agriculture c'est un temps fort de
la vie la vie française vous à
comprendre cette colère agricole
elle s'est manifestée manifestaient
depuis plusieurs semaines à niort à
angoulême à la rochelle à poitiers
précisément est-ce que vous la comprenez
personne n'accepterait de ne pas vivre
de son travail paxon personne
n'accepterait de travailler à perte
on en est au énième plan de sauvetage et
u10 annonce en juin 2015 annonce en
septembre 2015
surpris de la ville on le sait rigoler
on voit bien que se développe selon vous
pourquoi ça bloque selon vous et je
crois qu'il ya un moment donné il faut
que les annonces on compte qu'on passe
le cadre de l' effet d'annonce et qu'on
devienne une réalité là il ya urgence si
je vous entends bien sûr selon vous on
est toujours dans les faits dénonce ces
derniers mois le gouvernement a été dans
l'effet d'annoncé tout n'a pas été dans
l'action lire soir avant-hier soir ont
été annoncés baisse des charges
je crois que c'est effectivement
incontournable qu'on définisse ya eu
beaucoup de plans sur la banlieue sur
les villes sur les quartiers dénonce
également et il faut aujourd'hui qu'on
s'intéresse aux questions du monde rural
et 15 millions de français qui vivent
dans la rue
l'idée agricole mais aussi une agricole
il faut aussi que y ait des mesures
notamment fiscales de charge des des
zones palais commencé qu'orange avait
commencé comme ça selon vous c'est la
façon la plus rapide aujourd'hui de
prendre des décisions on peut pas
prendre d'édition sur le cours des prix
on est sur des débats qui sont à
l'échelle internationale donc les
premières décisions ces décisions que
peut prendre le gouvernement au niveau
national la question des charges est
impératif s'il y a urgence lors une
question l'élu en charge des
responsabilités ce que vous soutenez les
exactions pour autant dans la limite des
regards il ya eu des dégâts dans la
limite de ce qui est acceptable mais en
tout cas moi je comprends la détresse
je comprends je vis dans le monde rural
depuis plus de 25 ans dans ce
département
je comprends qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
personnes qui n'ont plus rien à perdre
et gigean culte et si j'entends bien je
vous vous comprenez des exactions
également voulez vous pardonner aux
exactions
je comprends la détresse et nous avons
une obligation de l'entendre
ça c'est capital et c'est urgent on ne
peut pas accepter qu'il y ait tous les
deux jours à suicide en france dans le
monde à l'école on passe l'épongé ou les
frais la ville de poitiers a dit
effectivement l'addition sera lourde
dans toutes les villes il ya
effectivement des nettoyages ça coûte à
la collectivité
il n'y a pas de poursuite à faire dans
ce genre dit seuls au monde agricole
cool ça coûte aussi beaucoup à ce pays
qui doit beaucoup au monde agricole
donc nous devons absolument tendre la
main au monde agricole par des mesures
qui ne peuvent plus attendre sur le fond
de la crise agricole bruno belin jours
et vous entendre vous l'élu qui connait
c'est justement le monde agricole
êtes vous favorable à l'encadrement des
marches dans la grande distribution
mais ça aussi soyons réalistes on va se
le dire le lundi et puis dès le mercredi
où vous trouverez un acteur de la grande
distribution qui trouvera le moyen de
vendre moins cher que moins cher
c'est la même difficulté dans le
commerce de proximité alors je vous pose
la question des mesures générales qui
s'applique
on part du principe qu'il doit y avoir
des zones franches dans le milieu rural
pour justement défendre le monde de
l'agriculture comme le monde du commerce
de proximité permettent la reprise de
petites entreprises ou du monde de
l'artisanat
donc en clair est-ce qu'il faut re
localiser les filières alimentaires
autrement dit si c'est pas possible de
fixer les marges plancher pour la grande
distribution
est ce que c'est possible de réaliser
relocaliser les filières alimentaires
je crois qu'il est surtout capitale que
on rentre dans l'opérationnel dans
l'effectivité des décisions crevits
nous ne pouvons pas mener les éleveurs
les agriculteurs en la faisant miroiter
des décisions qui sont sans effet ça va
accroître l'exaspération et ça je crois
que c'est mauvais pour ce pays tous les
professionnels agricoles le dise la loi
lme loi de modernisation de l'économie
votée en 2008 sous le gouvernement
sarkozy fillon a totalement déstabilisé
la filière agricole au détriment de la
grande distribution et les
transformateurs vous allez d'accord ce
n'était pas une bonne doigt dans ses
conséquences
on n'est pas là pour savoir si décision
d'avant-hier ou du mois dernier ont été
bonnes ou pas aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes acteur public
votre responsabilité est de faire en
sorte que la bonne décision sociale que
vous mettez en oeuvre
demain matin l'urgence est là il y a
aussi un état d'urgence pour le monde de
l'agriculture et pour l'élevage alors
autres grogne bruno belin c'est celle
des départements de france cure
d'austérité à tous les étages
rassurez-nous bruno belin est ce que le
département de la vienne est pas en
faillite comme celui de l'essonne ou du
nord où le département de la seine saint
denis
moi je suis solidaire de mes sens un
collègue autres présidents de
départements et essayer les deux temps
forts qui ont réuni l'ensemble des
présidents de départements 2015 les
décisions étaient unanimes quelles
soient élus de des départements de la
grande couronne où élus de départements
de gauche ou de droite
la réalité que depuis des années les
charges de solidarité sont plus en plus
forte et c'est important qu'elles
existent puisque nous soutenons le monde
pour répondre à des questions l'un des
participants aux faillites
nous ne sommes pas dans un schéma de
cessation de paiement comme d'autres
départements
'l'annonce mais je les comprends le
département du nord vous citez 2
millions d'euros par jour de
tarification de rsa en août le revenu de
solidarité active
donc ça fait partie quand vous n'avez
plus de ressources puisque effectivement
la fiscalité a été complètement revue
nous non plus que le foncier bâti et
qu'en plus il ya une dotation des bases
dotations de l'état
c'est que vous avez un futur candidat
aux élections présidentielles qui est en
train finalement de lancer sa campagne
en annonçant des baisses d'impôt d'un
côté mais qu'il arrive à compenser par
des transferts de charges et de baisse
de tension sur les autres en clair les
collectivités financent la campagne
du camp du président sortant candidat
voilà donc ce n'est pas évidemment
acceptable pour revenir au rsa est ce
que les bénéficiaires du rsa de la
vienne continueront à percevoir le rsa
oui pas d'inquiétude dans l'état actuel
des choses nous n'avons pas du tout
remis cette question
non parce que le département du
haut-rhin l'a soumis à des heures de
bénévolat pour le coup et ils ont le
courage d'ouvrir un débat est ce que
vous êtes dans une démarche niveau de
l'insertion de qui peut effectivement
nécessité je vais maintenant il vous
choque pas que le débat ait lieu ne me
choque pas d'autres départements
effectivement aussi lancé des pistes
nous réfléchissons à des pistes de
comment faire en sorte que on offre
l'opportunité de découvrir le monde
associatif la vie réelle avoir unique
sur un cv essayez d'insérer justement
les bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
presse pour le département de la vienne
65 millions d'euros d'euros par an c'est
ça oui on n'est même plus près de 70
millions d'euros maintenant donc avec
benoît colas qui suit c'est la critique
là nous cherchons nous réfléchissons à
des pistes pour permettre la meilleure
insertion possible des personnes
titulaires de minima sociaux et dans
quelle direction
débordant dans les directions nous
sommes maîtres d'oeuvre comme les
collèges ça c'est pour le bol annoncé sa
lettre il est important est-ce qu'on
peut accepter qu'ils aient cinq ou six
millions de français laissés au bord de
la route en dehors de la question du
poids budgétaire pour telle ou telle
collectivité
est-ce que vous pouvez accepter comme ça
un français sur dix soit laissée sans
considération non alors je pose la
question du licenciement de d'être utile
alors la question différemment
est ce que le rsa n'est pas du ressort
du politique publique nationale
renationaliser le rsa vous êtes
favorable ou pas oui nous le m
ça a été décidé par une volonté du
parlement comme le rmi à son époque
c'était une décision d'un projet de loi
gouvernemental validée par la pression
là-dessus et il peut y avoir une
ça ne choque pas que les départements et
l'action de deux présidents 11 dans les
affaires sociales départementales et
donc ça ne me choque pas que les
départements soient acteurs de
solidarité puisqu'ils sont acteurs de
proximité mais qu'on nous donne les
moyens de nos actions c'est pas
qu'actuellement l'état vous enlève
combien chaque année plus de 7 millions
d'euros 7 millions d'euros pour la
vienne en dotation globale de
fonctionnement donc c'est moins 7
millions vous avez trouvé ailleurs en
marge des économies c'est ça en budget
de fonctionnement vous à les renier quoi
1% c'est ça
pour l'année 2016 on est même un ennemi
% c'est-à-dire que dans la construction
du budget et 2016 de la vienne sur plus
de 300 millions de budget de
fonctionnement nous faisons cinq
millions d'euros d'économies ça c'est
pour 2016 qu'est ce qui va se passer
pour 2007
écoutez nous verrons ce qui se passera
mais on est la performance permanente la
recherche de l'optimisation de la
dépense publique
on se remet en question tous les jours
ce qui est normal on va poursuivre ce
justement ce débat autour du ldu la
gestion la bonne gestion et l'économie
des départements avant de poursuivre
justement sur ce sujet revenons à ce qui
s'est passé le 28 janvier dernier lors
des débats d'orientation budgétaire au
conseil départemental de la vienne il
paraît que vous avez fâché votre
opposition de gauche
je vous donnerai donne la parole après
mes reportages de luc barré pascal ep
coup d'éclat avant le débat des
orientations budgétaires
l'opposition de gauche conteste les
chiffres et décide alors de quitter la
séance
droit pas la possibilité d'intervenir
sans conteste plusieurs chiffres
notamment que la prévision au fait qu'en
salée d'augmenter les impôts donc on
parle bien de matraquage fiscal puisque
la taxe foncière et en prévision
d'augmentation entre 18 et 20% c'est le
crâne le premier sous la halle
les mots sont lâchés augmentations
d'impôts l'opposition dénonce une
volonté de la majorité de vouloir
fortement augmenté la taxe foncière sur
le bâti au coeur du débat le financement
du rsa le revenu de solidarité active
depuis plusieurs années les dépenses
liées aux aides sociales augmentent et
les recettes ne suivent pas vous avez
une partie des recettes qui sont les
dotations de l'état qui baissent
énormément puisque ces sept millions de
moins ça c'est du côté des recettes mais
le problème c'est que du côté des
dépenses c'est une explosion avec 8
millions 700 mille euros d'augmentation
de rsa et d'autres aides sociales
les élus du département espère donc que
l'état va augmenter les dotations sinon
dans la vienne le taux de la taxe
foncière pourrait connaître une hausse
de 3%
bruno belin voulez vous confirmer ce
chiffre d'ici le 7 mars prochain
plus constant que j'aime beaucoup leur
portage delebarre et il est vraiment à
l'image de ce qui est l'assemblée la
vienne où vous avez un camarade chef de
gauche qui très hésitant il sait pas ce
qu'il fallait faire ce matin là on voit
bien qu'il a cherché un prétexte plus au
contraire on voit là la sérénité de
claude et d'einstein le président de la
commission des finances
on sait on va la vienne est une force
qui va et qui sait où elle va et donc
former la caisse sur les impôts l'eau
foncez vous allez les augmenter mais
j'assume et je vous dire même faut être
encore plus concret que ça ça va être
pour donc les propriétaires la taxe
foncier bâti les locataires ne m'appelle
pas l'incidence est de l'ordre de 50 à
70 euros par an si les ça continue à
vous enlever de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement si l'état continue à être
sourd aux difficultés réelles de la
charge des allocations individuelles de
solidarité
l'incidence pour les propriétaires de la
vienne et de 50 à 70 euros par an
c'est-à-dire et s moins de 5 euros par
mois
est-ce que vous allez demander des
sacrifices aux agents de votre
département bruno belin nous considérons
nos agents comme des acteurs forte de la
mise en place de nos politiques du
précis sur le temps de travail
là aussi alors que le débat voire rien
vu mais j'ai vu que ce débat a eu lieu
dans dans d'autres départements moi je
n'ai lu que jamais les questions et donc
nous ne demanderons pas nous ne
remettrons pas en cause la question du
temps de travail chez les agents du
département de la vienne vous avez au
moins une réponse on ne peut plus clair
il nous a pas échappé justement le pod
collègue président du conseil
départemental et de sable gilbert fabre
lui est confronté à une situation
économique encore plus difficile que la
vôtre doivent faire des économies de
l'ordre de 15 millions d'euros cette
année
la réaction des agents ne s'est pas fait
attendre en début de semaine puisque les
annonces mouvement de grève pendant un
mois
ce qu'il faut s'attendre un effet boule
de neige au département de la vienne ou
parce que ça peut inquiéter non franck
il faut avoir alors que ce qu on appelle
ça une règle d'or
moi dès le deuxième jour de mon mandat
j'ai expliqué aux élus et aux services
que je voulais un budget 2016 avec au
minimum 20% d'investissement sa2 effet
cette décision là la première c'est
l'effet sur l'investissement aujourd'hui
les entreprises ont besoin de chiffres
d'affaires d'activité l'économie de
proximité l'emploi c'est ça et donc il
faut absolument tenir cet investissement
en permanence le deuxième effet ces deux
forcément compris mais le fonctionnement
et donc de réfléchir en permanence aux
économies le département continuera à
mettre des sous notamment dans des
domaines comme l'aéroport de poitiers
biard déficitaire l'aéroport de poitiers
biard personne n'en parlait où personne
ne s'en occupait jusqu il ya quelques
mois c'est là dans les collectivités
dont une vérité non j'ai volontairement
pris la présidence du fils syndicat
mixte de l'aéroport pour montrer
justement qu on y mettait les pieds et
qu'on voulait que ça fonctionne et que
ce soit un outil au service de la vienne
et de poitiers mais pas que l'on
continuera en plus attentifs à la place
de poitiers au développement de boîtiers
toujours à propos de deux structures
d'économie compte le département
continuera éponger le déficit de l'école
de commerce de poitiers c'est son rôle
là je crois que le débat enfin vous
voyez dans l'actualité au quotidien et
évolue nous devons avoir une école
d'études supérieures soutenait fortement
pourquoi pas mais en tout cas il faut
que poitiers et une école de ce niveau
là quel que soit son champ d'action le
département a deux pépites que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils gardent
jalousement c'est le futuroscope et le
center parcs
il vous a pas échappé nomme bruno belin
que la loi notre vous enlève la clause
de compétence générale
comment continuer faire faire de
continuer à faire de l'économie
quand on n'a plus cette clause par le
biais des sociétés d'économie mixte et
puis on s'est doté d'un outil aussi
important là il ya quelques semaines
justement fin 2015 évolution de l'
agence touristique vers une agence
d'attractivité et jean pierre raffin
vous le savez présent avec des maires de
saint benoît on va dans le semestre la
présenter des projets et je crois que
c'est une vraie chance d'avoir jean
pierre raffarin à la tête de cette
agence juste d'attractivité pour notre
département regroupe donc ce qu'ils me
voulaient nous dire c'est que le
département continue à faire de
l'économie par ce biais finalement est
ce que vous imaginez qu'on va arrêter
d'avoir des projets dans la vienne
la question était posée on est ici la
mort des départements sinon on leur
enlève effectivement cette clause ces
deux compétences et bien comment ils
vont faire pour pouvoir faire ce qu'ils
ont à faire
mais soyez assurés une détermination à
voir des projets de l'investissement et
ça ça fait de l'économie le département
de la vienne pour une obole en accueille
le congrès des départements de france et
6 5 6 7 octobre prochain donc à ap photo
futuroscope précisément c'est pour ça
que vous avez lancé les états généraux
de la ruralité pour pouvoir présenter le
bilan de ces états généraux
on a lancé les états généraux de la
ruralité avant de savoir quand même de
candidater
pour recevoir le congrès des
départements de france au mois d'octobre
et sur le sujet des étagères de la
ruralité on veut effectivement présenté
au mois d'octobre
fin septembre début octobre le livre
blanc qui est le résultat de plus une
centaine d'auditions mais qui va surtout
être résultats de proposition et de
fiches actions au service des
territoires je dis bien des territoires
un jeu repose pas la ville et la
campagne
la vienne dans sa globalité est un
département qui a besoin de sa ruralité
et qui est tourné vers la ruralité donc
il y aura des propositions concrètes
on profitera de ce temps fort que sera
le congrès des départements de france
dans le contexte qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui qui sera en plus un temps
fort à quelques mois d'échéances
démocratique capital pour notre pays
justement parlé et c'est aussi et vous
parler de ruralité le sujet suivant
concerne l'intercommunalité et on a
entendu les élus justement pas vraiment
content de cette la manière dont les
choses sont son agence et sa grande donc
également dans ce domaine
avant de vous entendre sur cette
question là voyez le reportage de luc
barré et le stéphane gourin c'était le
12 octobre dernier les élus de la
communauté de communes du val vert du
clain se mobiliser contre le projet de
fusion avec legrand poitiers une
mobilisation en vain hier la carte de la
future communauté urbaine de poitiers a
été voté les amendements déposés par les
élus du val vert ont été rejetés à la
mairie de jaunay-clan une pétition
signée par plus de 5000 personnes
affirmait cette opposition les élus
dénoncent un déni de démocratie aucune
concertation aucun projet présenté
notamment par le président du grand
poitiers
c'est quand même le grand politique a
plus besoin de nous puisqu'il veut peser
dans cette grande région et à aucun
moment il se dessine s'est déplacé sur
le territoire c'est un vrai mépris pour
les élus d'une part mais aussi pour les
habitants de ce territoire dans la
vienne le nombre d'intercommunalités va
donc passer de 18 à cette dictée par la
loi nôtre l'objectif est bien de
regrouper les communes et de redéfinir
les compétences des collectivités
territoriales comme pour le pays
châtelleraudais ou quatre communautés de
communes vont pouvoir travailler
ensemble la mutation économique
extrêmement violente qu'on convoi dans
l'industrie et nous sommes industriels
le maillage territorial complètement
différent il faut peser et il faut
exister
et puis encore une fois aussi la baisse
des dotations qui font que nous sommes
obligés de mutualiser nos efforts
mutualiser nos dépenses utilisez aussi
nos actions et je pense que la grande
agglo va nous permettre tout ça des élus
peuvent encore déposé des recours contre
cette nouvelle carte avant que la
préfète de la vienne la valide au 31
mars prochain pour une application au
1er janvier 2017
beulin sur ces questions de
l'intercommunauté on vous a peu entendu
c'est histoire de ne pas trop froisser
les susceptibilités
j'ai prié pendant 13 ans une
intercommunalité donc c'est un sujet que
j'ai pensé annulation vivre mais qui n'a
pas changé en tout cas pour celles que
dont j'ai été l'élu ce que dit jean
pierre abelin est très juste à dire il
faut de plus en plus mutualisés ça fait
partie des remises en question vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure le cadre
budgétaire des collectivités et donc
cette mutualisation
elle sera plus efficace à partir du
moment où les cartes sont rebattues
moi j'ai trouvé le débat de début de
semaine très apaisé la nouvelle préfète
de département à on est plus à
l'exception de deux ans sur la récemment
les syndicats des eaux là il y avait
d'abord écrit stats une crispation est
tout à fait à ce jour soit un véritable
sur ce sujet là moi j'ai vécu depuis
plusieurs années plusieurs c'est
d'essayer plusieurs commissions chargées
de l'intercommunalité et qu'est ce qui
s'est passé les deux haies ce qu'ont à
changer de préfet pour le coup je crois
que justement il ya eu la possibilité
que chacun s'exprime c'est la règle des
amendements
et puis volonté de l'état je trouvais
que la préfète a su effectivement mené
cette commission comme il le faisait où
chacun put s'exprimer
après si la loi n'est pas bonne il faut
se tourner vers le parlement se dire que
c'est quand même aussi une décision du
parlement de voir su cette procédure là
c'est pas une décision qui sert au
dégroupage ce gigantisme par la grande
région
gigantisme parler ces intercommunalités
aujourd'hui il faut éviter
je comprends pas par rapport aux états
généraux vous parlez de proximité
justement les schémas qu'on est en train
de nous présenter son des schémas qui
vont au contraire nous éloigner cette
proximité non aujourd'hui elle est
entérinée
donc il faut tout faire pour que
maintenant nous soyons efficaces
je crois que chaque fois qu'il ya débat
le débat est riche c'est important après
faut savoir se rassembler sur les engins
et donc les enjeux c'est que et c'est le
rôle d'un président département d'être
fédérateur pour que l'ensemble des
territoires trouvent leur place le rôle
et les outils pour qu'ils se développent
et donc je serai aux côtés de tous les
présidents d'intercommunalités pour que
là encore les territoires vivent
il nous reste moins peu moins de deux
minutes bruno belin justement je vous
entends sur deux questions purement
politique
votre mandat prend fin en 2020 dans le
président du conseil départemental 21
précisément on vous annonce comme
candidat à un poste futur poste de
sénateur est-ce que rumeurs fondées ou
infondées
je suis à 100% sur mon mandat de
président de département pour les années
qui viennent mais la casquette réalité
c'est d'ailleurs le mandat local et le
mandat national se noyer pas de ces
l'évidence est là où il n'y en a pas
donc aujourd'hui comme pour les mois et
années qui viennent je suis complètement
consacré sur mon mandat de président de
département de la vienne jusqu'en 2021
en 2016 vous nous annonciez justement
congrès des départements de france au
futuroscope en plein tempo sur les
primaires a eu du mouvement qui vous
vous êtes effectivement mais les
républicains vous bruno belin votre
champion c'est qui nicolas sarkozy bruno
le maire
fillon alain juppé je vais finir la
liste parce que tout le monde c'est là
encore des puits après vous proposer on
attend on parle de nathalie kosciusko
morizet on parle de frédéric lefebvre
moi je m'intéresse c'est effectivement
beaucoup aient des démarches qui
correspondent dans ma génération c'est
vrai qu'on a des candidats qui ont
aujourd'hui des dépositions qui qui qui
me plaisent
c'est à dire quoi ça veut dire des
candidats situe entre 40 et 60 ans au
delà c'est pas votre candidat est en
dessous c'est pas possible c'est ça moi
je n'exclus jamais faut pas être si
catégorique de ça il ya des gens bien au
dessus de 60 ans il ya des gens bien en
dessous de 40 ans ce qui est important
c'est que le débat ait lieu
ma position sera connue ce sera publiée
que j'ai jamais mis mon mouchoir sur mes
positions des années comme ça mais il
faut que le débat ait lieu et puis après
il faut qu'on se rassemble derrière
notre champion quel qu'il soit quel que
soit son âge
merci ce sera hugo de la faim bruno
belin merci d'avoir participé à
l'émission la voix est libre la semaine
prochaine la voie est libre invite
olivier falorni député radical de gauche
de la charente maritime
tout de suite c'est l'info bon après
midi et bon week-end
m
on